we're
sometimes the weed is just that
[ __ ] good exactly
kill this [ __ ] gorila gooing
[ __ ]
you
that's what I'm talking about [ __ ]
uncle Joey here July 5th you don't I
forgot about you [ __ ] I've been
busy all day to hell at the [ __ ]
house with the birds were chirping I
want to see the doctor I got some blood
taken out I went to the other doctor got
my [ __ ] package your goodie pills
I went midnight man Willy you know me
though always on the [ __ ] move
came back sent emails look this guy talk
to that guy but you don't give a [ __ ]
like how useless I don't give a [ __ ] so
I'll expect you to give a [ __ ] it's time
to burn this [ __ ] country down
understand me this time the burn is
brief and I really [ __ ] finished a
gorilla [ __ ] glue that [ __ ]
a memory
under then we can [ __ ] it back there now
we're gonna kill this [ __ ] Disney mr.
tail end of indeed oh [ __ ] that's music
to uncle Joey's [ __ ] ears you
understand today son when I walked into
the second doctor's office I was so high
she kept creeping I'm a little [ __ ] up
eyeball sometimes sometimes your balls
just give it away I was [ __ ] stoned
to the gills there's no needles there
was no knock go ahead and get [ __ ] it
beat it beat [ __ ] stomach you're
jealous man he sometimes got think of
him people spawn to the [ __ ] gills
but jump who gives a [ __ ] about reefer
philosophy let's finish this
[ __ ] right here and sit we've
stored a mockery up for the [ __ ] we
can I have a kiss the Stars a death
tomorrow good googly moogly
that
that's a [ __ ] doctor police
breathing techniques right there
if you don't know now you [ __ ]
know okay don't say I didn't tell you
I'll say you don't [ __ ] you got
[ __ ] amnesia whatever [ __ ] sign
there
have I told you [ __ ]
I love smoking reef and getting stoned
for the gills if I mention it you
[ __ ] because I really really do I
don't want to get drunk we in I want to
go jump up and down we don't go see
nobody
I just want to smoke two pipes you go
your way and I go [ __ ] mine like
journey in 83 and I'm saying separate
[ __ ] ways
even the Indians oh come on no one pays
the second set of smoke signals for the
Indians they said [ __ ] we can't run with
that crazy Cuban
hey [ __ ] around he's smokin em [ __ ]
pilgrim dust had that pilgrim had dust
I'm sorry I'm already seen the [ __ ]
family
nice
little reefer and oxygen I'm up here
they'll [ __ ] tree getting that fresh
chlorophyll with the [ __ ] Sun of
death little vitamin B fee and that's it
nobody dies everybody's [ __ ] happy
right I'd be scared of the [ __ ]
something like a vampire
you gotta get half take that little
vitamin D I mean you can't [ __ ] that
Cuban don't put on SPF number two you
see what happens you get bragging a
[ __ ]
well anyway pilot what about [ __ ]
skip town I'm just telling you don't be
scared this understand I'm hearing [ __ ]
right now I don't know what I'm Aaron
I'm just hearing [ __ ] people yeah you
can get [ __ ] raped and [ __ ] out
after that
when you smoke good really understand
I'll smoke my [ __ ] job oh [ __ ]
because bundle nuttin you know I don't
want to be [ __ ] cool get out it be
cool these [ __ ] you know bring
it on I to see the [ __ ] devil
I'm gonna finish up with this Paris so
cheap it's right [ __ ] you're on
TV right now you're on the land of oh
yeah
[Music]
jiggle this [ __ ] dust ice-filled
something [ __ ] brim alright listen
like I told you
this ain't about none this is us getting
together like family smoking a few
numbers and then you do what you gotta
do and I'm gonna do what I've never died
a little bit of the kid we gotta go
[ __ ] food China [ __ ] that the people
who see understand and that time to be
here chitchat with you [ __ ]
well I missed you today
I know our mission I was driving on
going I would [ __ ] of these soldiers at
that dorm to him this smokin [ __ ]
blow and smoking their [ __ ] boss's
face
oh yes it'd be a debt
oh I love it
people has Joey why do you get so
stomped so have to listen to you even
though you ever get too high people talk
to you just like not in your headline
and what are you talking I don't know
nothing
I don't know nothing about [ __ ] the
Stars or the moon I know that was going
deep and this is deepest will get me
understand me I gotta sit the passenger
seat
I love it but pays bespoke the best is
there anyway I guess tomorrow night 8
o'clock come at the spa tonight 10:45
father surprises for you this we got a
lot of [ __ ] comin you know I love you
[ __ ] I don't hold in the dark
but last person I have another have for
[ __ ] news
so imma hold over the gun understand I'm
just trying to spread love a little
reefer smoke and keep your head together
man there's times I'm losing my head
something happens there we are
oh I said [ __ ] you see what you
did to me you see what you [ __ ]
do to man come out this rope one bone
and they're smoking three bowls of death
with you you know what that makes me but
that means we got family putting it
together so anyway I love you
[ __ ] with all my heart
stay black have a good day now I have
this conversation again tomorrow get
ready for uncle Joey take your vitamin C
each oatmeal there's no coming in heavy
tomorrow on this [ __ ] like the big black
Kahuna